DEPARTMENT AND BILL BARR THINKS
THEY SHOULD PUSH TO FIGHT FOR.
WE WILL MUCH MORE ON ALL OF THAT
IN A MOMENT.
>>> THERE IS ALSO ANOTHER FORMER
MEMBER OF TRUMP'S INNER CIRCLE
FACING JUSTICE.
STEVE BANNON IS EXPECTED TO
SURRENDER TO STATE PROSECUTORS
IN NEW YORK DEVELOPMENT.
IT COMES AFTER HE WAS INDICTED
ON A CHARGES RELATED TO A
FUND-RAISING EFFORT TO BUILD A
WAR ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
KARA, WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING
ABOUT THIS LATEST STEVE BANNON
LEGAL SITUATION?
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING, KATE.
SOURCES TELL ME THAT STEVE
BANNON WILL SURRENDER TOMORROW
HERE IN NEW YORK WHERE HE WILL
FACE CHARGES RELATED TO THAT
EFFORT TO RAISE MONEY FOR A
BORDER WALL ALONG THE U.S.
SOUTHERN BORDER.
NOW BANNON, YOU MAY RECALL, WAS
INDICTED ON FEDERAL CHARGES
RELATING TO THIS VERY SAME
CONDUCT IN AUGUST OF 2020.
HE WAS THEN PARDONED BY FORMER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP AS HE WAS
LEAVING OFFICE AND WHEN THE
MANHATTAN DISTRICT ATTORNEY
LAUNCHED ITS INVESTIGATION
LOOKING INTO THIS SAME CONDUCT.
NOW, ACCORDING TO THE FEDERAL
PROSECUTORS, BANNON AND HIS
CO-CONSPIRATORS HAD RAISED MORE
THAN $25 MILLION FOR THIS WE
BUILD THE WALL EFFORT BUT THEY
SAY -- PROSECUTORS SAY BANNON
AND THE OTHERS SIPHONED AWAY AT
LEAST $1 MILLION THAT THEY USED
TO COVER SOME PERSONAL EXPENSES.
BANNON PLEADED NOT GUILTY AND
WAS NEVER CHARGED AND THAT CASE
NEVER WENT THROUGH.
TRUMP THEN PARDONED HIM.
BUT, YOU KNOW, STATE CHARGES ARE
NOT COVERED BY A FEDERAL PARDON
AND THE FACT THAT HE WAS NEVER
FULLY PROSECUTED MEANS THAT
THERE IS NOT AN ISSUE OF DOUBLE
JEOPARDY HERE, AT LEAST
ACCORDING TO NUMEROUS LAWYERS
I'VE SPOKEN WITH, SO BANNON WILL
BE IN COURT FACING THESE CHARGES
TOMORROW.
HE HAS CALLED THEM PHONY AND
SAYS THAT THIS IS JUST ANOTHER
PARTISAN POLITICAL WEAPONIZATION
OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
AND THESE CHARGES COME TWO
MONTHS AFTER BANNON WAS
CONVICTED IN WASHINGTON, D.C. ON
CHARGES THAT HE WAS FOUND GUILTY
OF CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS FOR
FAILING TO COMPLY WITH A HOUSE
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING JANUARY
6th.
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT.
JOINING ME FOR MORE IS CNN
SENIOR LAW ENFORCEMENT ANALYST
ANDREW McCABE AND COREY CORDERO
AND NATIONAL ANALYST DAVID
SINGERER.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WE WILL TALK ABOUT STEVE BANNON
IN A SECOND.
THE NEW DETAIL FROM "THE
WASHINGTON POST" MORE DETAIL IN
THESE HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS PICKED UP AT
MAR-A-LAGO, DAVID, I WANTED TO
ASK YOU ABOUT THAT FIRST.
THERE IS A LIST OF KNOWN AND
SUSPECTED NUCLEAR NATIONS, OF
COURSE, NINE OF THEM.
WHICH COUNTRY COULD THIS BE?
ABOUT?
>> THERE ARE NINE KNOWN NUCLEAR
WEAPON STATES AND IRAN, WHICH
ARE SEEKING NUCLEAR WEAPONS,
BELIEVE.
THE IRANIANS DENY THAT BUT
CERTAINLY PUTTING TOGETHER THE
MATERIAL FOR THAT.
SEEMS UNLIKELY THAT THE
PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE DOCUMENTS
ABOUT ALLIES THAT HAVE NUCLEAR
WEAPON, BRITAIN, FRANCE,
ISRAELI, STRIKES ME AS THE MOST
MOST LIKELY OR NOT THE ONLY
POSSIBILITY WOULD BE IRAN AND
NORTH KOREA.
WE KNOW HE HELD ON TO SOME OF
HIS LETTERS FROM KIM JONG-UN,
THE SO-CALLED LOVE LETTERS BACK
AND FORTH ON THE SUMMIT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS VERY
DETERMINED TO MAKE THE CASE THAT
HE HAD SUCCEEDED WITH NORTH
KOREA, EVEN THOUGH THEY DIDN'T
GIVE UP A SINGLE WEAPON DURING
HIS TIME, WHICH WAS, OF COURSE,
THE GOAL.
AND HE WAS VERY DETERMINED TO
SHOW THAT HIS SANCTIONS AGAINST
IRAN WERE WORKING, EVEN THOUGH
BY THE TIME HE LEFT, THEY WERE
GETTING CLOSER TO THE BOMB THAN
THEY HAD EVER BEEN.
SO IT SEEMS THAT THOSE ARE TWO
OF THE MOST LIKELY.
CHINA IS ALWAYS A POSSIBILITY,
OF COURSE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS DOCUMENT ACCORDING TO THE
REPORTING WAS FOUND, THE TIMING
I THINK IT IMPORTANT, IS A FOUND
AND RETRIEVED DURING THAT SEARCH
OF MAR-A-LAGO.
THIS IS A DOCUMENT, AT LEAST A
DOCUMENT OR MORE THAN ONE
DOCUMENT THAT TRUMP HELD ON TO,
DESPITE MULTIPLE REQUESTS FROM
THE ARCHIVES FOR MONTHS TO
RETURN.
>> RIGHT.
>> WHY WOULD HE HOLD ON TO THIS
INFORMATION?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT SOMEONE OF
THE BIG QUESTIONS.
IT CERTAINLY IS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI ARE
TRYING TO INVESTIGATE WHY HE WAS
HAPPENINGING ON TO THEM, WHETHER
HE WAS DOING ANYTHING WITH THEM
OR WHETHER THEY WERE JUST
RESIDING AT HIS RESIDENCE.
BUT I THINK IT ALSO UNDERSCORES
THE REASON WHY THE FBI NEEDED TO
EXECUTE THIS SEARCH AND WHY THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT MADE THE
DECISION TO GO TO THE JUDGE AND
GET A WARRANT UNDER PROBABLE
CAUSE TO BE ABLE TO EXECUTE THE
SEARCH, BECAUSE THE HIGH LEVEL
OF CLASSIFICATION, THE SENSITIVE
NATURE OF THE DOCUMENTS
INDICATES THAT EVEN THOUGH THEY
HAD ENGAGED WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S TEAM FOR SO MUCH
TIME, MANY, MANY MONTHS, THAT
THE SIGNIFICANT LEVEL OF
CLASSIFICATION AND THE NATIONAL
SECURITY IMPLICATIONS OF HIM
HANGING ON TO THESE DOCUMENTS
JUST DEMANDED THAT THEY FINALLY
GO IN AND SEIZE THEM.
SO I LOOK AT THE SEIZURE OF
THESE DOCUMENTS AND THE HIGH
LEVEL CLASSIFICATION AND THE
FACT THAT NOW WE ARE LEARNING
WHAT AT LEAST SOME OF THE
DOCUMENTS WERE ABOUT, JUST TO
UNDERSCORE THE REASON WHY THEY
HAD TO TAKE THIS INVESTIGATIVE
STEP.
>> ANDREW, WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT?
>> I THINK THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
I THINK THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE
DOCUMENTS, IT ELIMINATES ANY
QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THE DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI
ACTUALLY HAD TO GO IN WITH A
SEVEN, WHICH YOU'LL RECALL AT
THE TIME WAS PERCEIVED AS THIS
OVERLY AGGRESSIVE MOVE THAT WAS
TAKEN, YOU KNOW, KIND OF OUT OF
THE BLUE WITHOUT ANY SORT OF
APPROPRIATE WINDUP.
OF COURSE, WE NOW KNOW THAT IS
NOT TRUE.
WE KNOW THE PARTIES WERE NOT
NEGOTIATING IN GOOD FAITH.
WE KNOW THAT THE FOLKS ON THE
TRUMP TEAM WERE MISLEADING THE
GOVERNMENT, APPARENTLY, AT
SEVERAL POINTS IN THE EXCHANGE.
THEY HAD RESISTED THE RETURN OF
THESE DOCUMENTS FOR, YOU KNOW,
BASICALLY A YEAR AND A HALF
KNOWING WHAT WAS IN THERE.
THEY ABSOLUTELY HAD TO GO IN AND
RECOVER THIS MATERIAL.
IT'S ESSENTIAL TO NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> DAVID, REGARDLESS OF HIS
MOTIVATION OR THOSE AROUND HIM
FOR KEEPING THE DOCUMENT, DO YOU
THINK THERE COULD BE A REAL
IMPACT GOING FORWARD?
I MEAN, OTHER NATIONS NOW KNOW,
A FORMER U.S. PRESIDENT HAD
THESE HIGHLY SENSITIVE DOCUMENTS
AT HIS HOUSE.
I MEAN, IT'S DESCRIBED AS A
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT'S NUCLEAR
DEFENSE READINESS.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IT DEPENDS IN
LARGE PART ON WHAT COUNTRY IT IS
AND HOW DETERMINED THEY MAY HAVE
BEEN TO TRY TO GET SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION, IF THE INFORMATION
ISN'T ALREADY PARTLY OUT IN THE
PUBLIC REALM.
JUST BECAUSE SOMETHING IS
CLASSIFIED DOES NOT MEAN IT
HASN'T ALREADY BEEN WRITTEN
ABOUT.
OBVIOUSLY A LOT WRITTEN ABOUT
U.S. OPERATIONS AGAINST NORTH
KOREA, CERTAINLY AGAINST IRAN.
BUT THE FACT THAT THESE
DOCUMENTS, WHICH WERE AT LEAST
SOME OF THEM MARKED SENSITIVE
COMPARTMENTALIZED INFORMATION,
SOME OF THEM, WE BELIEVE MAY
HAVE POINTED TO HUMAN SOURCES,
WERE BEHIND BASICALLY A SINGLE
PADLOCK IN THE BASEMENT OF A
COUNTRY CLUB, EVEN IF IT'S
PRESIDENT'S OWN COUNTRY CLUB OR
EX-PRESIDENT'S, DOES SUGGEST
THAT SOMEBODY WHO WAS LAUNCHING
A SIGNIFICANT OPERATION MIGHT
HAVE GOTTEN TO THEM.
OF COURSE, THE BIG MYSTERY IS
STILL WHAT WAS IN THOSE SLEEVES
OF SECRET INFORMATION WHERE WE
COULDN'T FIND THE DOCUMENTS.
AND ARE THEY ACTUALLY MISSING?
HAVE THEY ALREADY BEEN RETURNED
TO THE GOVERNMENT?
COULD THEY BE IN SOMEBODY ELSE'S
HANDS?
AND ALL OF THOSE QUESTIONS NEED
TO BE ANSWERED AND THAT IS WHY
THIS IS GETTING SO COMPLICATED
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ANDY, ON STEVE BANNON, IS
EXPECTED TO SURRENDER TO FACE
STATE CHARGES IN NEW YORK
TOMORROW.
I WANT TO READ THE STATEMENT
THAT BANNON ISSUED IN THIS.
SAY THEY ARE COMING AFTER ALL OF
US.
NOT ONLY PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
MYSELF.
I AM NEVER GOING TO STOP
FIGHTING.
IN FACT, I HAVE NOT YET BEGUN TO
FIGHT.
THEY WILL HAVE TO KILL ME FIRST.
BANNON'S REACTION TO THIS.
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF INCENDIARY LANGUAGE
LIKE THIS.
WHAT DOES THIS DO?
>> WELL, I MEAN, THIS IS WHAT
STEVE BANNON HAS TO TRAFFIC IN,
RIGHT?
IT'S THIS KIND OF LANGUAGE THAT
STEVE BANNON USES TO ATTRACT
VIEWERS TO HIS PROGRAMS,
WHATEVER THOSE MIGHT BE, AND TO
ATTRACT SUPPORT TO WHAT HE IS
INTERESTED IN AND, ULTIMATELY,
AS WE KNOW FROM THE ALLEGATIONS
IN THIS CASE, TO ATTRACT FUNDING
TO SUPPORT HIMSELF.
SO IT IS -- THIS IS WHAT HE
APPEALS TO, THIS I AM STANDING
UP.
THE LONE MAN AGAINST THE
GOVERNMENT OR MAYBE IN TANDEM
WITH THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND,
THEREFORE, YOU SHOULD SUPPORT
ME.
WE KNOW THERE IS NOTHING TO
THAT.
CERTAINLY IN THE CASE OF THIS
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION WHICH I
SHOULD ADD, KATE, THIS IS NOT
GOING TO BE YOUR AVERAGE STATE
LEVEL FRAUD CASE.
THIS IS A CASE THAT WAS
DEVELOPED CAREFULLY OVER TIME AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL WITH ALL OF
THE RESOURCES THAT IT HAS TO
OFFER.
IT'S A CASE THAT THE FEDS HAVE
NOW CONVICTED TWO OF BANNON'S
FORMER CO-DEFENDANTS IN EITHER
ONE OF WHOM MIGHT DECIDE TO
BENEFIT THEMSELVES BY TESTIFYING
AGAINST BANNON IN A STATE
MATTER.
I'M QUITE CONFIDENT THAT THE
FEDS ARE SHARING THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY HAVE DEVELOPED AND
THEY ARE WITNESSES AND THAT SORT
OF THING WITH THE MANHATTAN D.A.
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS CASE THAT
NEW YORK IS APPARENTLY GOING TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH AND HE FACES
SIGNIFICANT JEOPARDY.
>> CARRIE, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
THE LEGAL CASE?
MUCH MORE TO LEARN BUT WHAT DO
YOU THINK OF THE LEGAL CASE HE
IS UP AGAINST?
>> WELL, I THINK THE FIRST PART
IS I'M CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT THE
INDICTMENT ACTUALLY CHARGES,
RIGHT?
IT'S VERY HARD TO ASSESS WHAT
THE CONSEQUENCES WILL BE IF WE
DON'T ACTUALLY SEE WHAT THE
INDICTMENT SO ONCE THAT COMES
OUT, THEN WE WILL GET A SENSE AS
TO THE AMOUNTS INVOLVED, THE
NUMBER OF CHARGES THAT ARE
AGAINST HIM.
THE CHARGING DOCUMENT MAY REVEAL
INFORMATION ABOUT GIVING C